Would you fall on a grenade to save your friends?
How about two grenades?
Jack H. Lucas did and became the youngest
man to be awarded the U.S. Medal of Honor,
the United States’ highest combat award.
Born Jacklyn Harrell Lucas in Plymouth, NC
on February 14, 1928, Jacklyn was a natural
athlete who quickly rose to captain of the
football team at his high school, the Edwards
Military Institute.
By the age of 14, Jack looked much older.
Relatively tall for his age (5′ 8″) and
brawny at 180 pounds, Jack had no trouble
convincing the Marine Corps recruiters that
he was 17 when he enlisted in August of 1942.
Notably, to enlist at age 17 (as opposed to
18), Jack needed a parent signature – so
he forged his mother’s.
Jack did his basic training at Parris Island,
South Carolina and qualified as both a rifle
sharpshooter and a heavy machine gun crewman.
In November 1943, he was assigned to the 6th
Base Depot of the V Amphibious Corps at Camp
Catlin in Oahu, Hawaii.
There he achieved the rank of Private First
Class in January of 1944.
However, after reviewing a letter Jack had
written to his girlfriend, military censors
realized he was only 15 years old.
He was then removed from his combat unit,
but rather than sent home (something he argued
heavily against), he was assigned to truck
driving.
Of course, being “in the rear with the gear”
was not Jack’s idea of military service.
Angry, he got into so many fights that he
was ultimately court-martialed and spent 5
months breaking rocks and consuming mostly
bread and water.
Released from the stockade by January 1945
and still determined to see combat, Jack walked
away from his post that month and stowed away
on the USS Deuel, a transport ship heading
toward fighting in the Pacific.
Because he left his assignment, he was declared
a deserter and reduced in rank to Private.
Now closer to the action, after hiding for
about a month, Jack finally turned himself
in on February 8, 1945, once again volunteering
to fight.
On February 14, he turned 17.
By February 20, he got his wish and was fighting
on the island of Iwa Jima.
During the battle on February 20, 1945, Jack
and his comrades were advancing toward a Japanese
airstrip near Mount Suribachi.
Taking cover in a trench under heavy fire,
Jack realized they were only feet away from
enemy soldiers in a neighboring trench.
He managed to shoot two of the soldiers before
two live grenades landed in his trench.
Thinking quickly, Jack threw himself on the
first grenade, shoving it into volcanic ash
and used his body and rifle to shield the
others with him from the pending blast.
When another grenade appeared directly after
the first, he reached out and pulled it under
himself as well.
His body took the brunt of the blasts and
the massive amount of shrapnel.
His companions were all saved, but his injuries
were so serious they thought he had died.
Only after a second company moved through
did anyone realize he was somehow still alive.
Jack endured nearly two dozen surgeries and
extensive therapy and convalescence.
Despite the surgeries, over 200 pieces of
shrapnel remained in his body for the rest
of his life.
Shortly after his act of heroism, on February
26, 1945, the deserter classification was
removed and he was restored to the rank of
Private First Class.
Ultimately all 17 of his military convictions
were also cleared.
Nonetheless, he was unfit for duty and discharged
form the Marines on September 18, 1945.
On October 5, 1945 President Harry S Truman
awarded Jack, and 13 other recipients at that
ceremony, the Medal of Honor.
Notably, however, at 17 he was the youngest
there and the youngest to ever receive the
award.
For his bravery and service, Jack also received
the Presidential Unit Citation, American Campaign
Medal, Asiatic-Pacific Campaign Medal, the
World War II Victory Medal and a Purple Heart.
So what happened after?
Besides graduating high school and earning
a business degree, at the age of 31, he enlisted
as a First Lieutenant in the 82nd Airborne
Division of the U.S. Army.
During his first training jump, according
to his team leader, “Jack was the last one
out of the plane and the first one on the
ground.”
You see, neither of his parachutes opened.
Despite this and an approximately 3,500 foot
fall, he miraculously survived with only minor
injuries.
Two weeks later, he was back jumping out of
planes.
Once he returned to civilian life four years
later, he opened a chain of beef selling businesses
in Washington, D.C., married a few times (including
one wife who tried to have him killed), and
later, with the help of D.K.
Drum, published an autobiography aptly titled,
Indestructible.
Jack lived to the ripe old age of 80, dying
on June 5, 2008 from leukemia.
A more recent individual who jumped on a grenade
to save another soldier was Lance Corporal
William Kyle Carpenter.
On November 21, 2010 while in Afghanistan,
a grenade was thrown into his sandbagged position.
Rather than run, he used his own body to shield
the other soldier with him from the blast.
Like Jack Lucas, though severely injured,
Carpenter lived and was awarded the Medal
of Honor in June
of 2014.